hey guys were here at the US air guitar
championship challenge craziness I'm
here with Ron and he's one of the
sponsors it's now what's your company
and why did you choose to sponsor an air
guitar competition
my company is Dutch tunes and we are the
largest network of digital jukeboxes
that's internet-connected Digital
jukeboxes in North America so we've got
and it's all about music and it's about
having fun so we thought what could be
more fun and have music involve an air
guitar
now you mentioned something about my
touch too much to my touch toons toons
calm or you can actually go online and
you can just register and then you can
create your own playlist I'm gonna make
an entire Bon Jovi playlist and I'm
gonna play have you seen the Bon Jovi
song and annoying everyone in the world
so we're here at the independent I'm
waiting
challenge thing to start so yeah we're
waiting air guitar
to the